Stephen King did a very nice thing
speaking on the subject of authors and
creators Stephen King did a very nice
thing he tweeted that in his opinion the
the best host for the Oscars would be
you and I think we have this and I
thought first of all he spelled your
name wrong
my name wrong I think it means someone
else yeah yeah well look he's good think
of the thoughts that guy has racing
through his head he's allowed to spell
my last day that's fine that's an honor
to have someone who's cool Stephen King
say Patton Oswalt should he should host
the Oscars how do you think you'd be as
an Oscar host look handle it look there
are a lot of potentially amazing Oscar
host out there yeah I think Tiffany
Haddish and John Mulaney would all would
be a mate but I think I would be a
really good Oscars host because I'm such
a film buff I would be so openly excited
to be up on stage the only drawback
would be the Oscars might be too long
with me hosting because I will be be
going by the way this this guy made a
movie is like his second one out he's
only in two scenes but he's so brilliant
you should really totally download it
you can get her on the criterion check
like every every host I would bring out
I would talk to them for like ten
minutes
yeah and bother them about their I may
be a forty four hour it would be nuts
yeah I'd be like like Harrison Ford come
on go
let's show his deleted scenes from
Zabriskie point let's just watch them
touches watch his scenes he's like can I
just present this work no no you sit
down Harrison listen and then I would
just show like all this but I would like
I would know I would be genuinely
excited just to be at the I would I
would be excited just to present editing
Awards and cost me more because I know
all those people's work and I would
actually be into that
so I would buy it would be like having a
radio contest winner hosting the Oscars
okay Helen Mirren oh my god
by the way really young she was in this
movie called age of consent with James
Mason and the movie sucks but she's
he's on the beach totally nude it's so
amazing oh my god like you could tell it
and people like please just let me get
my award